[Music]
millions of people watched mama to lose
300 pounds but the most shocking
transformation in reality TV history has
only just begun
I'm sorry I can't walk on him if the
world thought of size for dress was an
impossible goal what will they say about
a mama June's wrath wait till you meet
coach along I've been always on the
other side of the pageant I don't have
any talents now leave you would never
win this Samara come back never will
pumpkins unexpected baby I'm pregnant
what be the only new addition to the
family or will June finally find mr.
right
even when mr. wrong and his new wife
come looking for trouble
what are you doing here to talk about
some visitation what alone I won't take
your call look honey buns and win a
medical emergency threatens to tear it
all down Ilana we gotta take your mom to
the hospital
mama too must fight her biggest battle
yet every day
for someone someone someone the OL new
season of Mama June from not too hot
premieres Friday January 12th at 9:00 on
WE tv
you
[Music]